So last week in our staff meeting the conversation
came about after we were reading the book,
Contagious, and I asked the question from
everybody.
I said, hey, can you tell me why I make it
a requirement for us to read a book a month?
We've been doing this for seven-and-a-half
years.
Why?
And I got four responses.
One of them said, Pat, you want us to improve.
I said, okay, great.
What else?
The other person said, you want our minds
to be working and thinking about work after
hours.
That was an interesting one.
Another person said, it brings us together.
Because we're advancing together.
Another person said ideas.
And I said, "Everything is great.
But let me tell you why we read books."
I said, "I want all of you to want to make
more money.
How many of you guys want to make more money?"
And they raised their hands.
Now remember, this is not sales.
This is W-2 jobs.
How many of you want to ask for a raise and
to get a raise?
And everyone said, "I want to get a raise."
Now this is me, teaching my staff how to ask
for a raise.
I said, "There's three things that you need
to be doing to constantly be advancing in
your career.
And if you don't, you're not going to advance
in your career."
They said, "What is it?"
And I wrote it out, so I'm sharing that with
you.
One is attitude, effort, and progress.
Let me explain.
Attitude.
You'll have a lot of talented people in your
career that you'll hire.
I've hired so many incredibly ridiculous talented
people with bad attitudes.
And they don't last.
And they don't last anywhere they go.
Because anywhere they go, nobody likes them.
No one likes a bad attitude.
So when it comes down to attitude, a saving
grace for a person not to get fired, is a
positive attitude.
Because you've got three opportunities with
attitude.
One is a person that comes in, they're not
positive, they're not negative, it's just
no one knows they're around.
Nobody does.
You can walk by their cubicle 50 times and
they get fired one day, and you don't even
know they got fired.
Because no one knows their attitude.
Because you never see them.
Because they don't say anything.
So there's not a positivity or negativity.
At least you remember the negative person,
and you remember the positive person.
But you don't remember the person in the neutral,
right?
Negative ones, eventually, they're contagious.
Anytime I look at a resume somebody gives
you a resume to hire, I look at how many jobs
this person had the last two, three, four,
five years.
If it's multiple jobs, one after another after
another after another, there is something
there.
This can't constantly be the company.
Companies don't let go of good people.
They just don't.
They want to keep good people.
There's something that didn't work out six
different times, and most of the time it comes
down to attitude.
So then positive attitude.
We had an employee in the room and I said,
"Hey, let me talk to you guys about her."
I pointed out her.
And I said, "You know you almost got fired
six months ago, four months ago."
She said, "Yeah, I know."
I said, "How did you know?"
She said, "Everybody told me I'm about to
get fired."
I said, "Do you know why you didn't get fired?"
She said, "Why?"
So I had an executive meeting, meeting with
the executives, and I said, "This person needs
to get fired, that person needs to get fired,
let's keep these three.
Let's give a raise to this person," etc. etc.
We have these meetings.
I said, "You were on the verge of getting
fired because you had no clue what you were
doing with your job."
And she said, "Yeah, honestly, I had no idea."
I said, "But the only reason why we didn't
fire you, is because you have such a positive
attitude.
You're contagious to be around.
That's your saving grace.
You have no idea how valuable that is."
And she's like, "Oh my gosh, this is so amazing."
I said, "You stay like that, and you're going
to do great things with your life."
The next one is effort.
Let me explain to you the effort.
You know who the guys in the middle are?
I call them 7:59 to 5:01.
They clock in the minute before, and they
clock out the minute after.
I've got to go watch my T.V.
shows.
And there's no way in the world I'm working
one minute more for this corporation than
I'm supposed.
I'm not doing that.
I'm just not doing that.
Right?
It's like a religion to them.
Still cool, you're not negative.
Because these guys on the bottom, you know
what they do?
Let me tell you about their effort.
These guys for whatever reason, they're sick
on Mondays and they don't feel too well on
Friday afternoons.
I don't know what it is.
Their timing is incredible on when they don't
feel well.
Right?
Now I've worked jobs before and I know why
on Mondays because you want to have a longer
weekend and I know why Fridays because you
want to have a longer weekend, but eventually
people figure that part out.
I mean, everyone knows what's going on there.
These guys [positive] always move up.
I remember working at many of my jobs that
it goes back to, if we had to do certain things
at Bally's and I was off at 8:00 or 9:00 or
10:00, I was there till midnight.
I didn't have to be there until midnight.
I didn't get paid those hours.
No one paid me for those hours.
But I stayed till midnight.
Now what happened when I stayed there till
midnight?
One, I grew for myself, but people started
saying, "Pat's one of the hardest working
guys in the company."
I became the rookie of the year.
I got recognition.
I got those accolades, but you know what else
happened?
Let me tell you what else happened.
It prepped me that one day if I was ever going
to be put into an executive position, I already
know about the effort part.
I'm not afraid of working hard.
I don't mind putting in 12, 13, 14, 16 hour
days.
Because I've done it.
It's a muscle now.
I'm always going to be needed because most
people don't work that hard.
So for you watching this, I promise you, these
two [attitude and effort] alone, you're going
to move up in your career.
I promise you that.
Because most people don't work too hard, and
most people don't consistently have a positive
attitude.
These two, you'll learn the other parts.
Now let's get to the last one.
The last one is progress.
Progress to me is I call a meeting.
And this meeting, I say, "These five people
I want to be part of this meeting.
We're going to do an ideation meeting on a
new software, on a new technology, on a new
system, on a new product, on a new show, on
whatever."
I sit there, as the person who called the
meeting, and I watch on who's giving feedback.
The person that doesn't give feedback, I don't
invite to the next meeting.
For what?
You don't give feedback.
What's the purpose of you sitting there?
To look pretty?
I mean, listen, we don't get paid to model
here, right?
We get paid to come up with ideas.
Okay.
Cool.
The person that constantly comes up with ideas
and they don't get - what's the attitude - when
somebody gets ideas shut down and they become
defensive and they - they don't freeze.
When you say, "No, we can't do the idea right
now."
And they go like this [arms crossed].
Because you're too sensitive now.
Instead, this person says, "Okay, cool.
No problem."
Boom.
Next.
Because sometimes some ideas are just not
workable.
And they keep feeding more and feeding more,
and man, this dude's got a great attitude,
he's so enthusiastic about being here and
he's working hard, and he's giving great ideas,
trifecta, I like this guy.
Let's keep him long term.
Let's give him more responsibility and move
him up in the company and give him a raise.
That's the progress.
How can I make me better?
How can I make the company better?
How can I make the industry better?
How can I make this thing grow faster?
How can I make this thing look better?
How can we make the process safer?
How can we make this a funner place?
How can we grow better?
Everything's about better, better, better,
better.
And the one on the bottom is the one that
walks around and says, Oh my gosh.
I hate working here.
Did you hear what he said?
Here he goes again.
Oh, here he goes.
You know none of this stuff works.
Bitching, bitching, bitching, bitching.
These two (bad attitude, bad progress) become
best friends.
They're typically the same person.
Somehow, some way, they join the same club.
I don't know what it is.
They attract each other.
But these guys (good attitude, good progress)
somehow, some way, always move up.
I can't tell you why it is.
It's just what it is.
So if you're watching this right now, whether
you're an entrepreneur, whether you're a businessman,
whether you're successful already and an executive,
whether you're running a company that did
$180 million last year in revenue and you're
feeling like it's great, always go back and
take an inventory of yourself and the people
on your team.
How's the ideation of you constantly figuring
out how to make things better [progress],
how is your effort being put in [effort],
how's your attitude?
Take the assessment of your people and the
people that are there [positive], help them
move up and if you're somebody that's not
doing these three, try to become a trifecta.
Ask yourself every day, "How's my attitude
today?
How's my effort today?
How am I becoming better at making ideas and
progressing the company?"
And the more you do that, if the company you're
working at right now, treats you like crap,
and I'm talking sincerely, not you watching,
yeah, that's why I'm not moving up in life
- but you're really lazy - I'm talking you've
got a great positive attitude regularly, you
regularly work hard, and you always come up
with ideas and they still don't treat you
well, eventually, someone's going to take
notice.
That I promise you.
Eventually, someone's going to take notice.
You're going to move up.
It's inevitable.
It's a law.
It works for everybody.
So just focus on these three areas.
Mario, let's get our favorite pillow.
Okay, today we have Mario throwing us the
pillow instead of Paul.
We got two new team members here behind us.
One likes - you said comedy?
He like comedy.
And this one wants to be a producer is what
he wants to be.
And we just talked about the question why
Dane Cook is no longer, he hasn't been on
the scene for awhile.
Mario gave us some feedback why, that some
of you guys may remember Dane Cook.
Some of you don't.
But regardless, if you haven't yet subscribed
to this channel, let's see if I'm doing this
right.
Am I doing it right?
Is this good here?
The guys are trying to critique me on where
to put my finger.
Click here to subscribe to the channel.
And if you haven't joined the notification
squad, the crazy notification squad that within
30 seconds a video going up, you guys are
messaging, click on the alert to be one of
the first for YouTube to alert you every time
a new video goes up.
And join the notification squad.
And if you've got questions, comments, thoughts,
comment on the bottom.
Take care everybody.
Bye, bye.